I
FAMILY.
WHAT A COINCIDENCE.
ERIC SCHMITT IS THE MISSOURI
A.G. WHO WATCHED FAUCI SQUIRM
DURING THAT DEPOSITION AND HE
JOINS ME NOW.
WHAT WAS HIS BODY LANGUAGE LIKE
WHEN YOU WERE PEPPERING HIM WITH
QUESTIONS HE HAS PROBABLY NEVER
BEEN FORCED TO ASK BEFORE TO
ANSWER?
>> I THINK ONE THING THAT WAS
TELLING IS THAT IN THE SEVEN
HOUR DEPOSITION THE COURT
REPORTER SNEEZED DR. FAUCI
WANTED HER TO WEAR A MASK.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A SECOND,
NOVEMBER OF 2022 THIS IS WAS THE
MENTALITY OF THE GUY IN CHARGE
OF LOOKING DOWN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY AND DESTROYING LIVES AND
LIVELIHOODS.
VERY TELLING INSIGHT INTO HIS
MENTALITIES.
YOU COVERED IT AS -- HIS
DAUGHTER WORKED AT TWITTER.
YOU KNOW, HE -- HE SAID I CAN'T
RECALL 174 TIMES.
THIS IS COMING FROM THE GUY WHO
CLAIMED TO BE THE ALL KNOWING,
ALL POWERFUL OZ, RIGHT?
>> SCIENCE ACCORDING TO HIM.
HIS MEMORY LAPSED WHEN HE WAS
ASKED TOUGH QUESTIONS.
>> WHEN YOU ASKED HIM ABOUT THE
FACT THAT HE WAS TRYING TO COVER
UP THIS LAB LEAK, HAVE YOU
SMOKING GUN EMAILS WHERE HIS
PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT PROBABLY
LOOKS LIKE IT CAME FROM A LAB
AND THEN IS HE LIKE HEY, LET'S
NOT GO THERE.
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO SAY FOR
HIMSELF?
>> WELL, IN FACT, JESSE.
HE WAS PRIVY TO ABOUT FIVE OR
SIX DRAFTS OF ARTICLE CAME OUT.
PLAUSIBLE THEORY OPEN TO THE
LACK.
DISMISSING IT ENTIRELY AND
BASICALLY ANYBODY WHO COMMITTED
HERESY WAS TO BE CAST OUT AND
CALLED A CONSPIRACY THIRST.
THEORIST.HE DOESN'T RECALL ANY R
EMAIL.
LOOK, HERE'S THE THING.
THIS GUY WAS THE HIGH PRIEST OF
COVID TYRANNY.
WHEN THEY WERE SENDING OUT
SMOKING ORDERS TO CARRY OUT HIS
LORDS PEOPLE WERE CENSORED AND
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS WERE
RUINED IT IS A DISGRACE.
JESS THIS IS A GRACE.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
WE EXPECT THE REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE DOING THAT WE APPRECIATE
YOU DE